75 year old vicencia Aqua casts her
ballot with only the future of her
grandchildren on her mind
for our youths jobs for them so they can
have a prosperous life
but for many voters this election is
much more than just about jobs
let's say it's also about the future of
the country's democracy
benin's opposition is back on the ballot
after being excluded from the 2019
parliamentary vote a move that led to
Violent protests
president Patrice Stallone says the
election validates the country's
Democratic credentials
I think we are definitely leaving behind
the dark pages of our political history
the election was approached with
enthusiasm and no boycott
if the opposition gets into Parliament
with significant numbers some of its
candidate could run for president in
2026. under the current electoral law
candidates must be endorsed by members
of parliament and Mayors the opposition
also wants to get rid of laws that in
its word impede the country's Democratic
process
the election could also see a record
number of women elected to Parliament
nearly a quarter of the 109 seats are
reserved for women
water turnout however was low in many
areas a surprise to many after the
opposition candidates were allowed to
run
the election commission says it was
satisfied with the vote
even in the north of the country where
we feared Terror attacks there was no
incident
violence and protests that marred the
election three years ago haven't been
seen so far this time but whether it
stays that way depends on the results
and how the opposition and the people of
Benin receive them
how many degrees Al Jazeera cotonou